and Versailles.
spread.
intellectual point of view.
revolution.
Luis XVI, the king of Frances.
part of this conflict.
they are not happy.
other.
In this video we will talk about the French revolution.
And that makes that meaningful
is this independence from an empire controlled by the monarchy,
as in American independence, this is one
the perversion of monarchy.
A monarch that controls a great world power.
Depending on the cusp, the American revolution came
the first and in a way established the principles of self-governance
and the king's reasons.
But the French revolution marked the first time that these species
Principles were distinguished in Europe and perverted to the truth
a monarchy.
How to understand the type of environment in which it is
began, then talk about Francis of 1789.
Which most people consider as the beginning of
Pike first, France was poor.
Now, it is difficult to think that France was poor, if you look
If you look at Luis XVI and the clothes that were left behind.
If you look at Maria-Antuaneten, his wife,
they did not seem poor.
They lived in the palace of
Versailles, which is giant.
It is this grand palace, which can be compared to palaces
world's greatest.
They had a luxurious lifestyle.
If you want to know its location, it is now
almost one ... of Paris.
But at that time it was a village that was 20-30 kilometers
away from Paris.
So they did not look poor.
But Frances's current government is poor.
The poorest I mean are debt.
Just had two important military adventures.
One was the American revolution.
They play an important role in supporting
revolucionarve.
Because they wanted to oppose their enemy,
Great Britain.
They wanted their empires to diminish somewhat.
So France sent military assistance and sufficient resources.
And as you can imagine, this is not a bunch, especially because
is on the other side of the Atlantic Ocean.
Even before the American Revolution, the seven-year war
which ended in 1763, wiped out
the wealth that the French government had.
And for those who are more involved in American history,
the seven-year war is in reality the same as the war between Frances
and Indies.
The struggle between Frances and India was the North American theater
of the seven-year war.
But the seven-year war is the term with the general.
Because at the same time there was a conflict that took place in Europe.
The Franco-Indian War was just one
And the seven-year war really spurred most of the powers
European at that time.
France therefore participated in this, ended in 1763, then went on
the American revolution.
These both exhausted the funds
government.
At the same time, the French are suffering from starvation.
There was a general famine at that time.
No seeds were produced so nobody could do it
to eat bread.
As you can see, when people are starving
And as they add to their suffering, they could see
the royal family who lived well.
But, and worse, the royal family, whom they saw
every day they saw the noble.
Which contains more or less 1.5% of the population.
And they could see the nobleman who lived very, very well.
And the nobles, as they knew, consist of those people who
inherit titles, land and wealth from one generation to us
They do not wear too much of the kingdom.
And live especially in smaller versions of the palace
And in case you are a peasant, then you work their land, everything
work, it takes you some of your crops
and they do not even pay taxa.
Then from your point of view, which is not difficult
to understand, these are especially
some parasites that completely ignore it
urine tents and the fact
that you are paying taxa.
As you may recall, people were not very happy with this situation.
And above all, it was and
the presence of all these philosophers
Enlightenment around.
And in this kind of situation, people,
the authors, the poets, and the philosophers, leave to
think that perhaps the kingdom is not necessary.
Probably do not need priests to tell us what it is
good or bad.
Perhaps people could govern
surprise yourself.
And of course, the greatest proof of the Enlightenment was
American Revolution.
This was the first case of revolting humanity
and says the kingdom is not needed with me.
We want to rule ourselves.
For the people, from the people.
So this philosophical movement
Now, in my opinion, the greatest reason
I believe it was hunger, you can never underestimate
the power of people suffering from urine.
And it is
People said, here is Enlightenment.
Then this is the French state.
They had a financial crisis.
So there was a meeting, and types of emergency meeting
of the most important groups in France to solve
some problems. It's a tax crisis, people are starving
what can be done?